para sua escola que o verbo em 325 vai
ver que o vovô não sua longa
olá pessoal de quem fala é o dark sejam
muito bem vindos mas é um bela e os
estragos de que mais uma experiência que
eu adoro mesmo aí pessoal aqui em solo
já fiz dois vídeos que eu estou aqui há
muito muito tempo atrás e eu deixei os
vídeos como estava quente porque na
altura a minha pessoa estragou mas eu
comprei outra pessoal foi só o emerging
em bonita e com o passar do tempo nunca
mais um lembrete comprar uma pistola que
então agora sensual nós podemos voltar a
discutir coisas que vocês não viram
esses dois vídeos que estava quente que
eu fiz vou deixar uma embaixo pois vocês
podem ver mas mora lá pessoal e para
quem não sabe é uma pistola que antes
que ela cresce muito é por isso que se
uma pistola que né ela quer ter 600
graus é muito grau é uma graça e 600
graus não é brincadeira nenhuma porque
ela tem mesmo tudo ok claque ferro e
vidro ficaram que tal desvio elas
vinhetas ficava muito tempo a aquecer
mas a nossa específica por outro vídeo
não posso me sinto em casa aqui pessoal
deixe tudo comigo eu vou arriscar aqui
minha vida
vocês só vejam divirto e vai lá então o
que nós vamos tentar fazer hoje olha só
olha só eu vou tentar fazer pipoca corpo
estava quente não sei se já tinha feito
este experimento aqui e vamos tentar
fazer pipoca nós vamos tentar enfrentar
o cruzeiro este ovo só com a pistola
quente e vamos ver o que vai acontecer
será que vai cozinhar será que o
disponível foi de pedro e não só não só
vai ter vai cozinhar ou explodir mantém
o futuro vai tentar obter uma garrafa de
plástico mas já foi muito dura olha aí
basta que é muito duro mesmo então vamos
ver se é possível e outra coisa que eu
tenho aqui só para matar a curiosidade
só tenha que um tal eu lutei e venci e
mola e isso é de que os metais que é
muito usada em eletrônica para soldar
ferros todos nós que estamos aqui um
ferro quente e automaticamente do
crédito das duas uma ou não acontece
nada ou vai ficar com uma subida de
metal fábio tipo a que ela subia olha aí
pronto acredito já para lá então obter
aqui o nosso material mas antes pessoal
quer expandir muito é que neste vídeo
sério vocês não deixarem laico os meus
vídeos não vou ser mais recomendado para
vocês é porque o youtube agora considera
que quem deixa a equipe é quem gosta
realmente ver o conteúdo então eu sempre
vai recomendar para quem deixa lá então
se vocês gostam dos
os vídeos deixei muito light mesmo já no
início de ponto já deixou na época tenho
certeza que vocês vão gostar que se
vocês forem novos aqui no canal pessoal
e inscrevam é porque vai servir de novo
e muitas experiências loucas portanto
vejam a companhia embora então só
começar aqui queimar o nosso material
olha o que você está fazendo então vai
ser pipoca vamos tentar fazer a equipe
porque só que o pessoal aqui em le guen
tudo no chão já deixei que minha
história e vai lá só estou aqui encontra
milho em 32 o vai ser muito muito meus
16 10 para olha isso militar fugir do
concentrar muito bem o calor aqui então
as coisas vão partilhar a mesma boca o
meio da fugini a andar como for sempre o
que eu vou entregar um pouco pra mim não
fugir então bora lá 321 bairro
acho que agora vai agora eu não sei que
a mesma coisa e pipoca
meu deus só isso
brian laudrup pessoal em 321 my opt ok
ela não passa segurança não não tá prosa
professor fábio milho e faltava um pouco
do euro e isso carmen então mas mesmo
assim pessoal funcionou funcionou e por
que por que surgem aqui disse serra
a próxima coisa que nós vamos tentar
detê para só vai ser que nossa garrafa
quando ele é um clássico muito duro só
mas vamos tentar fazer alguma coisa
diferente porque eu sei que ela vai ter
toda completamente então eu vou tentar
fazer é sobre ter aqui um pouco a volta
e depois vamos tentar secar e ver o que
vai acontecer o plástico é igual a 32
sul vai eu acho que a não ser eu acho
que sim porque se aqui
e aí agora está muito bem e agora está
muito tempo mesmo
meu deus a proteja tanto tempo sol da
bandeira até agora bicho school vai eu
vou ficar com muita força da pulseira da
produzir olha só o que eu quero ficar
é preciso muita força do aço que é muito
duro não ficou bom então tentar deter a
nossa garrafa 32 culpa agora vai com
tudo à frente
agora vai continuar potência está
pensando em vencer o u1 fly london eye
vôlei futuro aqui você está ouvindo o
barulho é o plástico ainda quinta o som
comecinho que se muito mas vamos só
quando quer fazer aqui um pouco não se
faz e eu consegui esticar um pouco e
quase que torceu então é tudo o que eu
queria e para além disso em abril de um
buraco gigante ambev rafael ilha só
ficou muito grandes buracos boy tão
pessoal próxima coisa que nós vamos
tentar obter aqui olha só quem pode ser
para aí vai ser pai do céu eu tenho
conseguido assistir esta mancini porque
esta é assim e foi invencível pra mim
tudo isso primeiro ela agora vai ter que
ver é os nexos sempre muito estranhos
mas para ir à piscina
eu não fiquei porque não aguenta eu
tenho como fugir como na perna não da
unfp ok não significa eu vou só fazer
uma bolinha
ela só assim é em berlim uma só pistola
que encontramos assim a playdom em 32 o
vai máxima porque eu seja tabular na
muralha para o coro tem três buracos
num álbum só olha aí ô ô ô
não é tudo
ae léo
o pessoal isto parece um cometa olha é
isso que o espaço ou tá muito bom está
muito quente off fumaça assim até por
dente fica de frente ficou se com uma
textura mais mall mas mais finas do eu
acho que nós concluímos que o nosso
objetivo era destruir a nossa mas sim a
playdom e resultou muito bem então bora
lá o próximo objeto era lá que ser um
tal pessoal e vou fazer isso muito perto
de vocês porque eu quero que vocês vejam
o estudo então bora lá ok vou pegar a
pistola usada potência máxima e vou pra
cima
conseguimos todos o teu olho nisso
o u1 só ficou mesmo aquela sublinha que
eu tinha dito olha aí deu exatamente o
efeito que o cria então e resultou bora
lá então só tentar fazer o nosso povo
cozinhar ban em um escape para nós como
é e quer voltar com esse tempo só para
manter o ipi é o gosto ao pé e cozinhar
um ovo em todos os lados em todas as
partes eu preciso cuidar o prato e ir
cozinhando com o pessoal aqui e eu vou
tentar não usar a potência máxima que
brilham cozinhar bem e não queimar por
dentro porque é isso que eu quero fazer
o que sozinhas de kiev se iluda só
comentei muito o que acho que vai
acontecer ou vai ter vai cozinhar o flu
imitem eu acho que faz fluir é porque a
pressão do ovo lá dentro vai aumentar eo
flop por causa disso mas certeira do
vídeo ao bater mas para lá entrar passou
a pistola contra o povo em 325 vai ainda
não acontecer nada é porque há pouco
tempo e só usar o prato muito bem também
preocupa em ganhar muito bem por dentro
ok por favor não estou não estou do ovo
que não pode excluir ou eu não estou
muito perto méxico até agora está junta
há outra coisa pessoal todos os jogos
que eu tenho aqui são ovos fora de
validade fora do prazo
então mesmo que eu cozinho não vou poder
comer por fazer mal ao organismo e eu
também não estou feliz a comida
eu acho que mesmo assim não faria mal
seu começo mas com o mundo nunca se
brincar nem o o ou não já que uma vida
que outro corpo já chegaram a acionar um
explosivo só lá está a resultar
eu acho que estava desenhado chile é
muito bom chego muito bem claro quem
sabe cozinhar tudo conquistou o quinto
carne ovo pipoca tudo não é fofoca não
passar mal não é só deixar um pouquinho
de açúcar aí sim como pipoca fora do rio
machado e estou convicto que estuda mas
não pode pedir eu não posso ver tom
basta que se mantém outra coisa
completamente frente olha está bem
estranho
ok vou virar o ovo só pra cozinhar
melhor a parte de cima para abrir o olho
em 321 vai
a ram no crédito
eu nunca vi tanto calma calma calma
calma sua luta e espero quem sabe já que
nem é o crédito continua o mesmo
olha aí o leigo está brincando por
dentro de tudo que entra a viagem o
objetivo de dilma embora 321 vai o
núcleo de cozinha como podem ver gemma
explodiu mas é parte de fora ficou toda
bem cozinhada olha só como ficou sua eu
acho que nós contar deste experimento
porque a parte de dentro é claro fica
tudo muito bem cozinhado e mesmo assim
mas fico bem cozinhada porque o
costumeiro assim até sobre aquele que o
molho por mulher a taça liga nenê né mas
só conseguimos cozinhar um ovo e
conseguiu inverter tudo aquilo que nós
temos aqui então é só missão cumprida e
eu espero que vocês tenham gostado aqui
diz filho já sabem como tem mais coisas
por indústria que quando esta estava
quente por causa do returno mesmo que
este pequeno estado fiquem bem e se
aproximar